everything take
offer she was upset I don't know I think
she's personally drunk okay want to wait
a minute I think we're going to have her
dress mask so okay I'll meet you
over
wa
she's in the she's in the bathroom okay
she's uh she's my my son my son was
working I had two guys they work here
they there was something between the two
girls they start arguing she don't like
boyfriend she useless and said drunk F
great great thing my son my was working
drove them home and she's saying she's
falling us okay so all right do you know
what her name is by chance to report
what she look like you know she's like
the only chick in
there she just went there
probably it seemed like she was friends
with the girl she like the boyfriend and
they were
drinking she's like I'm calling you
sister okay are you the manager on duty
here tonight I'm the owner oh the owner
okay my son was a food owner so I had
him come off before I them home they
around the corner they work here
do you want her trespass or anything
from
here I just I don't want I don't want
any problem you want to cover get a ride
to get out of here I just I mean I'd
rather you guys just do what you do I
mean tring it's just it's ugly I don't
bad things on anybody but okay she's
obviously she's just upset about her
friend in the boy okay I don't know what
the story is but I'm like when they call
when they call you PD
are they home yeah they're all good
they're home he drove them off okay
that's the great okay that's the great
that's me okay now do you know what her
name is by chance no I
no okay all right when she comes out
we'll deal with her and everything I got
a couple units actually working the road
coming up here right now so
Ian I don't
know all right
so she's in the bathroom uh there's no
she's
in there's no drunk driver uh the one
that was driving his son was driving two
people that were drunk
home she she's hammered
apparently and I guess there was an
altercation between the people that she
that she was with that he drove home
that she doesn't like the friend and the
boyfriend or whatever
okay I mean uh angel angel she probably
tell you better I just came in I'm like
what's going on Angela's right
there Angie what's our problem is she in
there I don't know I didn't go in
there her issue um she was up here
drinking with one of her friends or
whatever and I don't know
she got here right she lost the baby and
all that
[Applause]
sh Sor
hello she's coming I
think we'll see listen this is going to
turn out really badly if I have to come
in there and find
you when you can just walk out
here hello this is my last warning
before I come get you and you're going
to go to jail did you call the
police
no what did you have an issue with
somebody up here no why are you up here
causing
problems I'm I'm causing problems
yeah
yeah find it and
leave it and leave yep you're getting
trespassed from here let's go trespasses
yep let's go
if you don't leave I'll take you to jail
I mean I'll go to jail I ain't got no
problems let's go you look familiar I
recognize you the I've seen you at the
barff I might have it with me sir I need
your ID yeah you'll get it you're right
I will we are from North Carolina baby
congratulations yeah
congratulations I'm on Facebook live
just so y'all know oh hi Facebook live
hi Facebook live
0026 66 to Jessie Jessie ain't got no
warrants congratulations yeah
congratulations y'all can do your own
little Shin dig I go to jail I don't
give a shit cuz I don't care he got
you're being trespassed and if you come
back to this piece of property you're
going to go to jail I don't give a shit
about come back to this piece of
property I reckon that's a good thing
though I'm going to jail y'all you're go
to
jail this
property leave now or you're going to go
to jail last war leave the property now
you're go to jail I
mean me you gave me I plenty of
opportunities don't no you
didn't no you
didn't playing with the wrong one but
you're going to end up you're playing
with me
bro
bro yeah now you're going to get a
battery on charge too she
10 shit I didn't do shit to
you you my face is God should have
kicked me no I did not kick you it's on
camera done no it is on the camera dog I
got it off Facebook live you piece of
shit you can tell the judge I will tell
the judge you got me on Facebook live
you piece of
shit can you please pick up get up and
I'll get your stuff up I'll get your
stuff get up and I'll get your stuff I
will why not me a chance bro you me a
chance no you didn't no no you
didn't no you
didn't you guys no you
guys
no you piece of
[Applause]
shit goodbye Facebook live she's going
to go to jail now Facebook live if I can
figure out how to stop
it that's a she theol man oh yeah she's
all she had to do is
leave you piece of shit Facebook live 82
2533 unit
242 they seen that shit
face
202 like your distur
and protect and you're not doing that
things that
is Ser protect y going to prison you
like I'm not even kidding man you were
given multiple opportunities to leave
you said you didn't care if you go to
jail I did
care6 oh no my sure I thought about that
before you used to leave and decided to
tense up resist us and then kick an
officer when you decided to kick an
officer you caught a felony shark oh God
I got a
baby should have thought about that
before you did what you did got PTSD bro
congratulations so do I I don't go on
kicking police officers you